a former model and Miss Israel winner
actress gal gadot has always been lean
and mean in order to play the title
character and Warner Brothers Wonder
Woman Godot had to make her body a
little less lean and a whole lot meaner
making the leap from models of
superheroes no easy feat but here's how
gal gadot got in shape to play Wonder
Woman real-life warrior it's well known
that Godot represented her home country
of Israel in the 2004 Miss Universe
pageant less well-known however is the
fact that as an Israeli citizen Godot
also served a compulsory two-year term
of service in the nation's military but
she didn't merely scrape through in sir
Burt I'm Godot dominated the intensive
three-month military boot camp and
earned herself a spot as a combat
trainer even still gadot said that her
training for Wonder Woman was actually
even more difficult than training for
the army I think being in the Israeli
army helps you with your training um it
was a lot more intense than this one she
loves sports physical fitness is a
lifelong passion for godot who learned
to swim when she was four growing up she
spent 12 years training as a dancer
while also playing tennis basketball and
volleyball
she told the SP MW that she's highly
competitive and that she always plays to
win otherwise why bother right in her
spare time she also indulges in rock
climbing all while taking care of her
two young daughters now there's a real
Wonder Woman diet of the God it may be
hard to believe but Godot actually
didn't go on an insane diet to achieve
her superhuman fitness level instead she
simply practiced moderation and common
sense using the tried-and-true method of
mixing greens with lean proteins to get
the most out of her workout she also
kept hydrating drinking a gallon of
water each day but she told Harper's
Bazaar that she more or less ate what
she wanted when she wanted and was able
to get away with it because she
respected her body's needs I look at
food as fuel and I want to give the best
of my body it's all a matter of
measurements and quantity of the food
just enjoy your food and don't eat while
you drive and don't eat when you talk on
the phone just give the food the respect
and give yourself the respect to enjoy
it a beast in the gym in order to
prepare for the role of Wonder Woman
you don't spent months working with
professional trainers when she started
she couldn't execute a single pull-up
but by the end she was ripping through a
daily routine that included rowing
machines stationary bikes broad jumps
crab walks pull-ups push-ups squats ball
exercises and weightlifting
she may use a sword and a lasso in the
film
there's no question that she could bust
out a gun show whenever she wants no
cheat days when you're a superhero you
don't get any days off after all the
world isn't going to save itself
that's why Godot trained six or seven
hours a day every single day for half a
year and that training wasn't confined
at the gym alone she also had to undergo
ultra intense weapons training to learn
how to properly use a sword and shield
but the most difficult part of her
training surprisingly it was horseback
riding she explained it all in
Australian news interview I also thought
I was going to love horse riding because
it always looked as if it'd be easy it's
not it was super painful and I had tons
of bruises she defeated Conan ever
wonder what might happen if Wonder Woman
battled Conan well we learned the answer
during the DOS promotional tour of
Wonder Woman except it wasn't Conan the
Barbarian she faced off against it was
Conan O'Brien claiming he would
accomplish in 35 minutes what took a
dote months and months of everyday
training
Conan O'Brien bragged about his three
months of girl scout service before to
dote in her trainer critiqued his less
than heroic physique afterwards gadot
showed off her powerful high kicks
before battling the comedian and sword
fight if there's one thing to take away
from this segment is that gal gadot can
not only dominate with her high kicks
and physical prowess but also slay with
their stunning good looks personality
and charm she's a wonder that Wonder
Woman thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel Plus check all this cool stuff
we know you'll love to
[Music]